this is an update for Bitcoin if you
haven't read the Bitcoin soon update
that I posted last night on Twitter
please go and read it because it's quite
complete and I might give you some more
information okay but so far we can see
in Bitcoin in the four hour time frame
is that we had a deviation here above
the 50ma then price doom and if you
notice price actually Doom
um a four percent okay then price went
back up another variation then we saw
another drop of let me check
another four percent all right and now
you set another deviation here
okay so if prices are from here
and we expect another four percent that
could take us to the 50 of the week at
twenty six thousand sixty six okay so
that's what I'm keeping an eye on
um now you have to also go into other
time frames for example in the one hour
time frame you can say that right now
you know we are right below resistance
so the most lucky thing is that the 50ma
pushes the price down okay and also you
can see in this one here okay quarter of
weeks to the upside
here but price is now breaking out of
this Zone okay so that might tell you
that the market maker is built in shorts
all right so naturally what we're going
to expect the Bitcoin drops from here of
course the invalidation would be if
Bitcoin can actually break above this
50ma okay come back to it tested a
support then that would be a very good
entry point because then you would
expect an upside
and here you can see that there are some
liquidity pools okay they are not very
big but of course there are some
liquidity pools
uh let me Mark them for you
so that's at 27 000 and 27 245 so that
would be a setup in in the context that
Bitcoin can actually come back up break
up of the 50ma and go but to be honest
at the moment again I'll tell you all
these weeks to the upside
are only telling me that monkey make it
is building his shorts okay so we're
gonna expect price to go down from here
more important things you know we had
two weeks here so this one is the most
important one because here you have a
difference of price of
500 all right
um with this one you have a price
difference so 400 or 350 dollars or 400
400 all right so these weeks are very
important now you can see that they came
all the way to the 50 of this week and
then they Bounce from here towards the
one hour 50ma right so this would have
been a nice setup but again what
expecting price to go down right
um where to
well to me it's clear let me remove this
50 of the week because we've already hit
that Target uh at least you know I'm
still targeting the 50 of this week I
think I mean I'll tell you like this
okay I'm not happy until they feel this
week and that is gonna be my target
until they until they get there all
right I'm being quite clear with that
you know I'm not being careful sharing
my ideas I'm telling you okay this is my
trading system I'm expecting the 50 of
the week to get filled okay so that's
what my trading system is telling me
okay that we need to see this fifty
percent of the week all right now I'll
tell you again we lost this Support over
here
okay just please
um well actually we haven't lost it yet
okay but we might lose it soon all right
and is that level over there you can see
that they are you know testing it as
support testing it's a support testing a
support but we still have this week
all right if it wasn't for this week I
could tell you all right yes this is
looking like you know we might see some
kind of around here okay
and then go higher the bull with this
week over here
uh I'm February still lower prices I'm
favoring that we go to this week
hopefully we can't see this we're
getting Phil at the start of the week
all right and now I want to go to hablo
Capital because there is something quite
interesting there yesterday I was
working on the charts and I saw
something that got my attention Okay and
last time that we talked about this we
were right and it happened so let me
share my theory with you okay
let's check those Liquidations in the 12
hours time frame first
okay you can see that there is some
liquidity at 26 975
uh this is because you know that is
spiking price up in the same Zone but
they are not breaking above it so always
there is always some liquidity right
above previous highs and also below
previous low so that's what you see all
the liquidity there okay now could this
mean that we might see a stop hunt you
know a little pump to the upside right
at the start of the New York session to
hit all those liquidations before we see
a drop
I mean yes why not it's possible okay so
I do have to keep that in mind but now
let me show you keep that in mind if
we're going to the seven days time frame
we have spoken about this liquidity Zone
since last week 27 800 okay
um this is quite an important level you
can see that there is quite of liquidity
there but again
we're not favorable in those prices as
long as we are below
the 50ma in the one hour time frame and
in the four hours time frame okay I hope
that's clear so if you see I've stopped
right at the start of the New York
session okay and it goes to 27k and then
it gets reacted then we're gonna favor
lower prices but if it goes higher
then it goes to the 1 hour 50ma tested
the support okay then you can see a pump
and who knows maybe we see actually they
started getting hit but I'm telling you
if I look at the chart right now
I can only favor lower prices because
what matters is what we are seeing at
the moment and what we are seeing at the
moment is that we are below too
important levels okay these are those
EMAs in the one hour and in the four
hours time frame and this is the most
interesting chart in my opinion the
three months time frame okay because you
can see a lot of liquidity here
the set of liquidity at twenty five
thousand four hundred these are very
important tool in the chart
um I'll go again through the chart later
or I've explained this for quite some
time also 22 500 this liquidity Zone it
hasn't moved for moons I will tell you
okay
um in fact it's it's getting brighter
this this bar so it's telling you that
there is more liquidity here even now
and of course to the upside quite
important that's why we're gonna go now
in a second in back into Bitcoin and I'm
gonna tell you really quickly in a
minute the high time frame analysis
but the most important thing in this
time frame is this okay what we saw
recently happening here okay you see
this week to the downside at 25 800 but
you have to wonder why didn't they bring
this wig all the way down okay hit those
liquidations and then bounce
and I'm gonna tell you what I think
last time I said this it was I think
last week and it played out okay and it
was in a different time frame but it
doesn't matter because they
price action you know it happens in a
one minute time frame and when you see
in the one minute time frame it also
happens in the five minutes time frame
15 minutes time frame one hour time
frame four hours time frame daily weekly
time frame monthly time frame it doesn't
matter at the end of the day price
action is still the same you see the
same behavior in the candlesticks okay
so what I think is that this pump here
is a room for liquidity okay what does
that mean that means that they haven't
hit this on here of 25 400 and they've
come instead to 25 800 and then bounce
because within this bounce they know
that there is going to be a lot of
little Trader that they are thinking oh
that was the dip it's pumping now I'm
gonna buy I'm gonna go long all right
and that's when you see this area
getting brighter because if you check
here okay check this one here and check
this this Zone here you can see it's
brighter now
okay because there is now more liquidity
in the zone because the retail has
opened Longs here it's open in lungs
all right so when they open Longs with
high leverage their liquidations are
going to be in this Zone too that's why
if they're coming out to this Zone and
they attack these liquidations they are
gonna get more okay
I mean this is a roof estimation of
hablo Capital but you can see that in
this one there is 55 billions worth of
liquidations
that was
10 days ago okay right before the week
and now we have 60 billions okay so you
can see that it has increased almost a
10 percent
that's what I mean guys that's why I
think this is a rune for liquidity and I
think that we are gonna see still lower
prices
and this pump call it ball trap or
manipulation as you want I'm gonna call
it run for liquidity okay because that's
what it is they are running up just to
gather more liquidity in this zone so
when they come to this one again
we are back in Bitcoin okay so let me
remove all these drawings
um let me tell you what I think
in higher time frame okay so we have
this one over here okay what we saw you
know a sell-off then price went back to
the Zone we saw another sell-off and to
be honest we haven't tested this on a
support yet okay so this was a very
important resistance that we haven't
tested our support yet so that's what I
think that price should eventually come
to this Zone okay
this is 25 200. all right then you also
have the 50ma in the weekly time frame
in this Sono right so that's quite
important and if you remember you know
the liquidation Hitman that we've just
seen the three months time frame in high
block there is a lot of liquidity in
this Zone at 25 400 okay so that's
telling me essentially that this zone
right here okay this blue box here it's
as soon it's as soon in the chart that
is the most interesting at the moment
right that's what I want price to come
to this Zone and see what it does
because in this one what price could do
all right is come here
test this Zone as support hit all these
liquidations and then bounce and go to
and go to higher rise right or what I
can do is come to this Zone lose this
lose this level all right and then you
can see price you know going lower where
to what you have this liquidity pool
over here that's at 22 000 also remember
the liquidation heat map 22 000 we had
also a massive liquidity zone right so
that's an interesting story in the chart
you also have this week over here okay
so that's you know if we lose 25
you're going to see 22 and potentially I
believe 21 ish 20 700 okay so that's why
I think that this one in the chart that
is 25 200 okay between twenty five
thousand two hundred and twenty five
thousand four hundred that's the most
interesting Zone in the chart and we are
only you know one thousand dollars away
from it so why not why wouldn't you
expect price to come to this Zone okay
maybe we see some kind of fake out could
be to the upside or it could be to the
downside okay and then you could see
something like this all right but price
needs to come to this Zone 25
000.
225 400 ish so I hope that's clear guys
um we are still keeping an eye
on this week over here okay
uh this week is done
they've already fill the 50 percent
exactly to the dollar right that was
like this that week is done but we still
have this big week here okay and that's
around twenty six thousand sixty six
dollars I think it was
so foreign lower prices but if we see in
the one hour time frame a flip of
resistance into support of the 1r50ma
okay then I'm gonna enter along in in
this Zone okay at the retrace of the
50ma okay and I'm gonna favor
this one over here
that is twenty seven thousand seventy
five and also 27 240 right so that's
pretty much everything guys I hope that
was useful I hope that was clear
and I'll see you soon